για απολλούς και διάφορους λόγους μετά από μια συνεπή παρουσια στην πρώτην κατηγορία μειδικών τους
γύπεδο με κόσμο γι επαρχία δηψά για πάσκε και τα λοιπά έει ακαδημίες και υποβιβάστηκε
όταν ήρθαν οι ανθρώποι δης ένώσης καιμαθέλουμε την ευκαιρία να παραμείνουμε δεν μπορείς να τους
άχουνοήσεις δεν μπορείς να γνωησής μια υπάρχεια δεν έχει στην πολιτέλεια να το κάνεις αυτό
μια νομάδα που τα παλαιότερα χρόνια ήταν από τους πρωταγόνιστεακρίνετα ακριβώς αυτό θέλω να πω
και καικυρίως είναι και εγο γγεογραφικά δηλαδή το πάσκε έχει ανάγκη την ελευθερή μπεριχήνα μοοτοόπότα
βλέπε είναι διάφορα τα κριτήρια που βάζεις και αίρνει στην απόφαση ώρα κάποιο μπορώ να
πουν ότι υποβιβάζει στο προϊών σου υποβαθμίζει στο δεν υπάρχει σταθέρατρα εγώ διαφωνώ γι αυτόν
κιεμε πέρμαχος αυτιστής πολιτικής είμαι ο πρόεδρος άρα πρέπει να επερασπίζουμε κι τις πολιτικές μου
αλλά μακάρη να εμπορούσαμε να είχαμετη δυνατότε να να γνωρίζουμε νεκτων πρωτερο δε θα νενία
ιδόδακα αν και κτινάυψυτη δική μου το τέλειο φορμάτπραθλήματα ς είναι ίνα ενα είναι οχτώματας
την πρωτην κατηγόρια ίσως το ιονόσ ότι πλλέ ομάδες παράδωσιακά πρωταφωνιστέ τις καλαθώσσφεράςαποσωματία γινάνεταιρίες το
μεγαλύτερο μέρος στο πυρά αντα αποδόσφερι τοπό το σφρικών τμήμα ίσως να είναι και ανάσαπα
τους λόγους στο οποίο οι καλα θώσφερα υποβιβάστηκε εγκάποσησαβογικάναι είναι σωστόν αυτό που λες και
ο έχουμε ζήσει ιατ υπάρχουν τα παραδίμα τα ακόμα και σήμερα τα δικετικά συμβούλε υάζονται
πρωτερετετους εννοείται ότι πρώτερεόητα στα σωματία τα οποία έχουν όλα τα θλήματα μεγάλα σωματί μεγάλά
ενόση βασυν κόσμου να μην τα εία συ έχουν όλα τα θνιμα όλα τα θλήματα
σίγουρα το συμβύλε βάλει πρωτερεόττας και δυστυχώς υπίτ θα η μεγάλη επείτυπάοτοποδόσφερον και μετά είναι
μπάςκεις πόλεγαανάλογος αυτό το πράγμα υπηρεάζει ναι όμως υπάρχουν και σωμάτια τα όοία να καθαρά
καλα ασφέρικα κι τα βλέπει ς όπω τον καγνώ ανατα χειλ ου είναι καθαρά εκεί
και παραμένουν καισι και πρώταονιστούνεμαι κλείνοντας το μήνυμα που θέλει α στίλει αντρέας στον κόσμο